my guest tonight is an emmy
award-winning comedian who spent
a lot of time here at largo over the
years also a lot of time with me
over the years her new podcast is called
confusingly the sarah silverman podcast
you'll never guess who's on please
welcome our good friend the hilarious
sarah
silverman sarah so lovely to have you
here
that was uh that was incredible that's
the best reaction
anyone's had since we started having
guests back is that true
that is true that is andy wouldn't you
say that's probably the best most
authentically happy reaction we've had
that's true but half of the people here
sarah brought with her that's true one
i brought my lover
um you know i am i've admired you
over the years i really have not just as
a comedian but as someone who i consider
to be a
spiritual wanderer and adventurer
i mean that i'm not talking religiously
i mean
i'm talking about the fact that you you
seem to care about people and connecting
with them
i love connecting with people i like
well you know there are comics that
don't like people in their comics that
do like people i
i'm a loner in my life but i do like
people
and i'm interested in i know this sounds
hippie dippy granola or whatever but
energy like it's i feel like that's i
don't feel i know it's real like the
energy what do they say like it cannot
be uh
created nor destroyed energy cannot be
created or destroyed that's true
yeah so like but it can convert so
you know like someone gives you the
finger on the freeway
it like gives you bad energy and you
pass that on and it's catchy but like
good energy too can be catchy this is my
point
but i believe in this because i think
growing up
in the 70s and 80s i picked up bad
energy and i've just been passing it on
ever since
yeah which is fun by the way i think
it's hilarious i read that about you on
your wikipedia page
it's it's the first six paragraphs of my
wikipedia page
i uh i believe that though you get that
energy you give bad energy
you seem to yeah you don't believe in
the mind-body connection how do you
explain nervous diarrhea
that's the question that many people
have pondered and
you've cracked it you can't yeah exactly
i mean
that's what a great statement i've seen
this
in life you describe yourself as someone
who likes people i've noticed that
there's some comedians who are not
themselves when they're with other
people they're
they're you see their persona on stage
and then you see who they are backstage
you're always yourself
and you seem like you're a positive
person like you're trying to convert
everyone's energy to good energy is that
true
i try to i when i'm conscious of it i
mean obviously i can
i'm sure i can be a dick you know but
like ora
would i don't mean to make it a male
body part but you know what i mean
right an [ __ ] yeah um yeah
but uh i was at going to the weed store
actually right around the corner from
here and i pull in
and i you know parallel parking is hard
for anyone and then i
i go up i go up a little and then i back
up
and the guy in front of me was in his
car i i i didn't even really kiss it i
didn't touch his car i really didn't but
he must have been in a really bad place
who knows what was going on in his life
he was this big guy in a big suv he gets
out of his car and starts screaming at
me and he's like
you hit my car and you know
and i uh i i didn't hit it but i just
went
sorry you know there's i go i'm sorry
because oh you're sorry
you're sorry i guess that makes it all
better then right
and i can't even do anything about it
because you're a girl you know like
which is like were you gonna
punch someone and um
i and so i i i took a second i go
my heart was pounding but i go here's my
chance to try to like convert energy
so i work up my you know guts and
everything
and i uh get out of the car and i go up
to him and i go
i i'm gonna make this right show me
where the scratch is i'm gonna fix it
let me pay for it
no forget it i go no i want to make this
right but you know there was no scratch
there but
he's like just it's fine and i go
i'm gonna buy you weed and then he
laughed a little i go
he goes no you don't have to i go what
what kind do you like
he had like a russian or ukrainian
accent but i'm not good at accents
yeah he goes uh i like the kind that
gives you a full body high
indica indica it is
so then i go into the weed store and i'm
waiting in line
and as i'm waiting in line i see the
meter person what do you say for meter
maid now
well uh me to say meter reader meter
reader there you go meter reader
a meter reader but my car is kind of out
of view but i see the meter ear i go oh
with all this
commotion i didn't put money in my thing
uh
so then the uh bouncer come there's like
a security guy
at weed stores and he comes in and i go
i know i got a ticket he goes no
your new friend over there put uh money
in the meter for you
that's fantastic so i i get the pot and
i come out i give it to him and i go
i heard you're my hero he goes then he's
all bashful oh it's
nothing you know and then uh he shakes
my hand
and i hadn't shaken anyone this was a
few months ago i hadn't shaken anyone's
hand but i go oh
screw it i'm going to shake his hand
i'll just puree out later we shake hands
like oh look at us
we were arch enemies and now we're best
friends and he was laughing
and then as i pulled out he like took it
upon himself to like guide traffic
you know that's kind of sweet but see
see this is the thing most people in
that situation if someone's yelling at
you in a car
they yell back and it escalates you know
you did the thing that no one does which
is you say how can i make this right
i'm going to buy you weed if we all went
around offering each other weed
things would be so much better in this
world i agree
yeah that's all we ever needed i think
you know speaking of positive energy
this theater you know that you've
performed here many times
um this theater the largo theater has
all these pictures backstage
there must be 15 pictures back there of
you
and there's at least 15 pictures of gary
shandling who played here
all the time and i know that you and
gary were super close
do you think about him a lot even even
today oh yeah
all the time boy i miss him so many
don't you
you were close to them too yeah
sometimes i would call him or need him
or
you know he was first of all
just seeing you and talking about gary
makes me think about
either you or him were hosting the
yummies mm-hmm i think you were also
i was hosting him and i got gary to do a
bit where we rode together
on a horse on a horse and we had such a
good time
doing that i was sobbing laughing at
that bit
yeah yeah he was it was a bit that
called for me to be riding a horse and
him to be behind me holding me and it
was a romantic
on a beach in malibu and
uh yeah i've i saw that clip again
i don't know maybe about a year ago and
teared up because he
looked so happy in that moment because
it was so silly it was such a silly bit
to do
but he was lovely i ran through all my
material i used to run material past him
and as you know he was a great teacher
and he was so
unselfish about listening material and
he would listen to my jokes and go
that's good okay that's good that's good
wait a minute that one
i don't quite get and i go like it's
gone if he didn't like it i would just
take it out immediately
he was honest but he was so supportive
he was a mentor to so many people
you know we a bunch of us played
basketball and they were like there are
ncis scripts he's helped people with you
know what i mean like
he's he was so those were the really
neurotic crimes i remember
when uh yeah when uh mark harmon asks if
his
hair looks okay
but um yeah and it's funny because
every he was so generous like everything
he learned the hard way
he gave to us on a silver platter yeah
and i remember at his memorial a friend
was like
who's gonna be our gary now and i was
like
we have to be the gary's now you know oh
when they asked me i said steven seagal
oh god
i think your answer's better your answer
is more zen i specifically thought we
need a new gary
and quickly said stephen cigar yeah you
can see that now in your comedy
[Laughter]
there's a lot of like low ponytail yeah
and
just a lot of side kicking um you had a
birthday recently you turned 50.
keep it down i'm just kidding how'd you
worry about
it how'd you celebrate uh
you know it's funny because i usually
don't
uh usually i just have dinner we go to
like um
this place down the street called lucy
el adobe oh i know that place yeah it's
just like a big old mexican restaurant
it's cheap it's
you know that way it's like because i
know it's the one night it you know it's
like
they that i probably won't be paying
it's just like
burritos and stuff right and uh
i but i really don't like presents i
mean it's not that i don't like presents
i just but i
do see them as like burdens like i don't
like
stuff yeah like i just where am i going
to put it i
i feel like james spader and sex lies on
videotape like i just i only want one
key
so my best friend tal john yeah you know
how he's tall
that's why we call him tall it's the
name tall john non-ironic uh nickname
but uh um one time my birthday he came
in with a wrapped gift and i go what are
you doing and he goes
open it and it was like a tennis racket
i loaned him three years before
so it's like he knows me that's your
idea of a good gift you don't want
you know maybe getting something you
lent someone two years ago or
like socks are always good like i'm you
know but i just i don't know i don't
need stuff but it was so funny because i
turned 50 and i
you know it's a big birthday and tal
john
who's now my neighbor got me like
a massive gift he got me an an electric
bike
whoa it's so awesome like it
feels like a motorcycle i feel so cool
on it like got a helmet and everything
but you know he turned 50 before me and
i was like thinking back at what i got
him and it was like
not even at all didn't match because he
got you an electric bike what did you
get him
i got him a a t-shirt that says uh keep
calm and eat my [ __ ]
that would be funny on a real big tall
big guy yeah
no you you got one better expensive
[Laughter]
uh your podcast i mean you're perfect
for podcasting you're very funny
uh you're terrific with people and i
know that you're getting the word out on
it you posted a picture
recently to drum up uh subscribers for
it
i think we have the picture here and
there you go
this is your way of saying listen to the
podcast is by showing your your bare
butt is that correct
yeah i actually took it just to send to
my boyfriend rory like you know he loves
my tucus
but um then i go screw it i'm gonna post
it cause i need people to subscribe
you know i don't think about that stuff
i love doing the podcast and people
watch it and they
on youtube or they listen to it uh
or they watch clips on instagram and
they think that means they're watching
it which i'm the same way i know
but you know you have a podcast like
they have to press the subscribe button
or to keep you on the air and it's just
they just you need to get them to press
the button it's just so stupid but
so this is your way of saying listen to
the podcast
i mean i don't know i think it i'm going
to do that from my podcast oh my god
your little like pink freckly
tush um yeah yeah it's very
i have a very very small very small butt
very like it's kind of non-existent it's
not even there yeah it's just like the
end of your
back yes it's my coccyx
and it just sort of just goes straight
down and that's there's no
there's back to leg and there's nothing
in between see what i'm saying
it's a straight drop you want to think
about it some more
let me really picture it
oh yeah i see that yeah erotic huh
yeah you've been uh just my boner
i've never done that before that was
weird
uh i'll you know we've been talking
about this a little bit lately
uh this is we're gonna do three more
weeks of the night tonight show
and then sort of wrap that up and i've
been thinking about
some of the people i've really wanted to
talk to before we do that
you've been coming on my show since the
very beginning
i mean 28 years
your first time was in 93
which is right when we got started which
blows
my mind we have a picture i was 22.
you were 22. there's a picture of you
isn't that insane
appearance first of all you look
fantastic you look amazing
your face is exactly the same your hair
is changed um
but my teeth look smaller now i think i
had to grow into my face
yeah your teeth are still the same size
but your face got a lot
bigger i see what you're saying i talk i
talked like i it was i had like an
affectation
you know like a comedy like hey oh you
did
i conan yeah i'd be like
someone asked me for my number and i
gave him a fake
number you know i felt so bad
so i moved there well explain the thing
is please
that's how i talk it's a good joke
organically talked but
you know i think one of the things
that's really interesting is when you're
22
i was 30 i think when when you came on
the show because that's
that's how old i had just turned 30 when
we started doing the late night show
and it takes a while to figure out who
you are
yeah comedically and so it's
it's not that you were trying to be
someone else's you're just trying to
figure out how to be you
oh yeah it was i was me then yeah i
thought oh my god look at that
why was i sporting andy look at you why
andy why was i
dressed like tom jones in con what was
that jet
or i'm dressed like the riddler or
something no you were probably trying to
seduce sarah that's my
yeah it does look like i lured you to my
apartment
and put up and put on my sexy guy jacket
to try and trick you into liking me
uh i thought it'd be fun uh since you're
here to show some of my favorite
things that you've done on the show over
the years
first of all um i want to show this clip
if you don't mind uh
and i don't want to spoil it so let's
take a look oh yes i came up with a
craft
that you can do with the phone okay
anyone can do it
and uh let's see it would take like
either one of you can do it get
like turn to your head to the side okay
like this like this
and then just let your mouth be loose
and natural and maybe put but put your
lips together
and put your tongue out just a tiny bit
[Music]
well a little more tongue
okay okay
wow
oh
i love your show so much i do
i love it so much the first time i ever
was recognized on the street was
from your show oh is that true yeah
because you'd always have me on
and i've been on your show for so many
years i like grew up on your show i
honestly feel like i
my whole death reel could just be clips
from your show i'd be happy
i say aim higher i say you have a lot of
life left
so rack up more stuff more clips it'll
nudge our clips out of the way you'll
see
well listen i uh i want to make sure i
mention you can listen to the sarah
silverman podcast on itunes and wherever
podcasts are available
click on that click on that yes and
conan needs a friend
blair no i would just meant it i do oh i
see
you were mentioning the podcast i really
do
need a friend uh we love you and
um you know we're going to keep knocking
around in comedy so
we'll do other stuff together but thank
you so much for being such a big part of
our foolishness for the last 28 years
and i'm i just i'm just
so happy i love you too there that
stopped that
sarah silverman everybody
you